y la ciencia el pensamiento científico
el racionalismo científico pues está en
crisis han empezado a surgir esta serie
de grupos que pues han puesto en jaque
el pensamiento científico que creíamos
los occidentales pues que era tan
poderoso que muchos seguimos
considerando que es muy poderoso pero
que también tenemos que reconocer que el
surgimiento de estos grupos tiene que
ver también con la soberbia de quienes
hemos hecho divulgación científica la
misma soberbia que habita el periodismo
perdón yo soy periodista o lo fui hace
muchos años pero también los periodistas
así como los divulgadores científicos y
los científicos pues nos creíamos los
únicos en el caso del periodismo capaces
de narrar historias por ejemplo y en el
caso de los científicos o de los
divulgadores pues nos creíamos los
únicos con el único método capaz de
explorar la realidad o de hacernos
preguntas sobre la realidad entonces
cuando yo traigo esto simplemente es
para decirles que tenemos una crisis
compartida un dolor compartido el cómo
llegar a las audiencias cómo conectarnos
con la salud
no solamente está haciendo que ustedes
desaparezcan pues el malo acá el lugar
donde yo trabajo estuvo a punto de
desaparecer hace dos años y medio cuando
yo empecé a trabajar ahí estábamos
completamente quebrados pues no había
salario ni para los empleados estábamos
a punto de desaparecer y de la capacidad
que tuviéramos para resolver como no
desaparecer dependía o no el futuro de
maloka y pues que hicimos hicimos una
cosa de la que hemos hablado aquí toda
la noche en la que creo que todos
coincidimos y es en el poder de las
historias pues eso era lo único que
teníamos en la mano en ese caso la
historia que teníamos que contar era una
historia que nos volviera a ser
necesarios para esta sociedad porque
pues en ese momento ni los colegios ni
el sector público ni el sector privado
creía que valía la pena quema lo que
existía era que un museo de ciencias
existiera ese mismo año desapareció por
ejemplo el museo de ciencias de los
niños y pues prácticamente los únicos
que quedamos en divulgación científica
pues somos el planetario y ahora malo
que es la historia que contamos
y poderosa para convencerlos a todos
fuimos al consejo fuimos al gobierno
local fuimos donde los empresarios y los
volvimos a hablar de una cosa pues que
creíamos novia pero que no era hoy para
qué sirve la ciencia en una sociedad
para qué sirve que los niños desde
pequeños y los jóvenes le cojan cariño a
la ciencia y eso sirve un poquito para
cosas que hemos discutido esta noche y
es para fomentar ese pensamiento
científico racional el sentido crítico
la capacidad de discernir y hacernos
preguntas distintas sobre la verdad
entonces pues esa historia sí fue muy
poderosa la supimos contar no de manera
masiva no a través de ninguna plataforma
pues la contamos en medios muy análogos
como el consejo de bogotá pero lo
hicimos también que en estos dos años y
medio pues hemos conseguido 9.5 millones
de dólares y rescatamos a maloka de la
mano de muchos actores y maloca pues ha
sobrevivido pero pues hasta hoy no hay
un día en el que yo no me pregunte cómo
no desaparecer
y la segunda cosa que tuvimos que hacer
pues fue los contenidos que es un poco
pues la pregunta que todos nos estamos
haciendo esta noche y para eso también
nosotros teníamos que cambiar porque
veníamos hablando hasta ahora de lo que
hablaban todos los museos de ciencia y
los museos de ciencia que han hablado
tradicionalmente de las ciencias físicas
y exactas
cuando los museos de ciencia nacen en el
mundo pues fue como el juguete de todos
los físicos pues ellos fueron los que se
crearon los museos de ciencia para poder
contar sus experimentos de manera masiva
y así digamos sobrevivieron durante
muchos años pero resulta que ahora
también todos los museos entraron en
crisis y tuvimos que pensar que otras
historias podíamos contar que tuvieran
más relevancia para la sociedad en la
que pertenecíamos y esas historias
entonces empezaron a hacer o lo que
pensamos es que tenían que contar
historias de las ciencias humanas y
sociales
fue lo mismo que hicimos o que hice pues
cuando estaba de directora en el
ministerio de las tic s por cierto es el
territorio más agreste para un humanista
yo no sé hacer otra cosa que no sea
humanista aunque he estudiado muchas
cosas de administración pues estar allá
era muy raro porque todos eran
ingenieros todo el mundo está hablando
de tecnología de transformación digital
y a mí lo que me parecía muy raro era
que nadie se estuviera preguntando por
el comportamiento de los seres humanos
como nos estaba cambiando el
comportamiento la tecnología y
puntualmente eso que suponía para la
cultura colombiana y pues cuando estuve
ahí en esa dirección lo que hicimos fue
estudiar mucho de la mano de las
ciencias humanas y sociales de
antropólogos de cis de psicólogos de
sociólogos hicimos varios estudios para
entender justamente cómo la tecnología
nos estaba cambiando la forma de actuar
y a partir de esa información pues luego
la volcamos en políticas públicas y en
programas y en todo lo que estábamos
haciendo para cambiar un poquito ese
comportamiento de los colombianos en las
redes que en ese momento
pues es bastante violento entonces yo
eche mano de las ciencias humanas y
sociales y en este momento en maloka
hicimos lo mismo para cambiar los
contenidos y que empezamos a hacer pues
lo primero hicimos una exposición que
inauguramos este año que se llama la
ciencia del amor y el perdón y esa
exposición lo que quería era pues
queríamos hablar de paz sin hablar de
paz porque ya no se puede hablar de paz
porque se volvió político pero para
proponerle digamos una reflexión a la
sociedad sobre ese tema encontramos que
había más de 900 grupos de investigación
en el mundo que habían encontrado una
correlación entre el perdón y la salud
del hombre es decir las personas que
eran capaces de perdonar mejoraban pues
su respuesta ante el dolor los latidos
del corazón tenían mejor salud que las
personas que no eran capaces de perdonar
nos hicimos una alianza con la
universidad de stanford que llevaba diez
años estudiando sobre el tema y volcamos
todo ese contenido en una exposición con
quienes trabajamos psicólogos sociólogos
antropólogos neurólogos por supuesto y
ahí salió es expuso
qué es una exposición itinerante que
hemos empezado a vender por todo el país
el segundo contenido es uno en el que
estamos trabajando y que también partió
de una realidad y era pues observar un
poco lo que estaba pasado pasando en
nuestra plazoleta maloka está ubicada en
salitre y sal y tres del barrio donde se
ubica la terminal de transporte de la
ciudad desde hace dos años y medio
desfilan por ahí las familias de
venezolanos recién llegadas con las
maletas con los niños con hambre y con
frío y la reflexión que le pasó a los
museos de ciencia es que no podíamos
seguir hablando experimentos científicos
cuando en las terrazas o en las
plazoletas de nosotros teníamos
realidades muy pertinentes y no vi
locales que no estábamos abordando en
los museos de ciencia aquí un poco
volvemos a tocar puntos que hemos tocado
toda la noche no podíamos seguir
hablando de contenidos que eran muy
globales pero que poco tenían que ver
con la realidad local entonces empezamos
a trabajar en un proyecto para hacer una
exposición sobre la migración venezolana
esa exposición lo que quiere es hacer un
trabajo de sensibilización sobre la
xenofobia
creíamos que la xenofobia es una
enfermedad europea y hoy es muy muy
colombiana entonces estamos empezando a
hacer esa exposición y ya nos hemos
encontrado pues dos grandes socios que
nos la han financiado casi toda está
hablando un poquito de modelos de
negocio pues siempre hay que monetizar
es la obsesión todos los días pero creo
pues que haciendo este tipo de
contenidos que son locales que tienen
mucho que ver con pues con la sintonía
de la ciudad y el lugar que que ocupamos
en esta sociedad pues también es una
manera de monetizar suena muy cruel pero
si no nos conectamos con esos contenidos
pues también sería muy difícil encontrar
aliados que era un poco lo que le estaba
pasando a maloka pues unos años atrás y
es que seguíamos hablando de los
contenidos que nada tenían que ver con
la realidad local entonces hicimos esa
exposición la vamos a inaugurar el año
entrante estamos trabajando en ella y
esto pues simplemente para decirles o
quizá volver a conectar
todas estas reflexiones pues con la
pregunta que me hace mauricio para estar
aquí parada y es cuál es el talento que
necesita pues la economía naranja dentro
del futuro del contenido y yo creo pues
que son dos cosas
un un talento el otro no sé en qué
categoría cabe pero pues el primero el
que hemos hablado toda la noche el poder
de las historias pues ya por xy tarot
najar ar y pues me me escribieron pero
bueno es que es muy poderoso ese cuento
al final han sido las grandes historias
o son es el poder de contar historias lo
que nos ha transformado como especie y
es único en la especie humana el poder
de contar historias hizo todas las
especies cooperan todas los animales los
insectos las todos cooperan pero la
capacidad de cooperar de manera masiva
es lo único que logra la especie humana
a través de las historias y a través
pues primero en los mitos de las
religiones de los cuentos de los miedos
de las culpas pero también de la plata
ahora nos están haciendo cooperar a
todos pues con los datos no esa es la
nueva religión antes fue la libertad
pero fueron todos esos
antes mitos e invenciones de la
imaginación y en la capacidad de contar
historias lo que nos movilizó como
especie lo que nos hace cooperar a gran
escala entonces primero talento que
necesitamos el de contar historias ahora
quienes van a contar esas historias y
aquí estoy súper conectada contigo
cuando uno mira por ejemplo los talentos
que se necesitan para la cuarta
revolución industrial a mí hay uno que
me llama poderosamente la atención y es
uno que va a estar en desuso y sé que en
desuso a estar la escritura y la lectura
y yo digo o sea a mí no se me ocurre
pues a lo mejor es lo que dice felipe
pues no no lo tengo en mi cabeza pero
como a poder como vamos a tener personas
capaces de contar historias que no saben
leer y escribir pues porque bueno
supongamos que no las tengan que
escribir pero pues para hablar pues toda
la estructura del pensamiento funciona a
partir de la creación del lenguaje y
pues hoy tenemos pues las redes sociales
capturada por completo la atención de
todas las nuevas generaciones y la
concentración de los nuevos entonces no
sé quién va a quedar para contar esas
historias cuando estamos perdiendo por
completo el uso del lenguaje
pero bueno primero pues primer poder el
poder y el talento de contar historias
es súper necesario para seguir siendo
relevantes y otro talento que considero
pues crítico este si viene del método
científico tiene que ver con la
capacidad de seleccionar entonces las
redes o todo el contenido que nos están
botando es una nueva forma de censura
porque la censura era cuando nos
bloquearon información pero ahora nos
dan tanta información que no podemos
escoger y es lo mismo o sea somos tan
ignorantes como cuando nos censura van
temas entonces un talento absolutamente
crítico es la capacidad de concentración
de escoger de seleccionar eso viene del
sentido crítico y pues la capacidad de
obviar de votar todo lo que nos haga
ruido o lo que no sea pertinente y pues
en este escenario en este auditorio sí
creo que existe esa capacidad gloriosa y
poderosísima de saber poner el foco
sobre las historias que vale la pena
contar las historias pues que van a
seguir siendo relevantes
y también creo que solamente en este
tipo de salas con este tipo de liderazgo
está algo que considero tremendamente
crítico y es la capacidad de romper esas
cajas de resonancia de las
conversaciones de las redes sociales a
mí me parece brutal cuando dicen que
escuchemos a las audiencias y que
escuchemos a los públicos y lo que ellos
quieren porque quienes ya han hecho ese
experimento de solo escuchar de lo que
la gente está hablando pues el resultado
fue la elección de trump o el break
sheet y no sé si él no en colombia
también tuvo algo que ver con eso pero
es importante pues salirnos de esas
cajas de resonancia de esas
conversaciones de las redes sociales
porque entonces qué va a pasar con
contenidos como los míos los de
divulgación científica que son
contenidos difíciles que son contenidos
largos que efectivamente suponen que la
gente se concentre un poco más tiempo
para poder entender un concepto pero si
no somos nosotros estos líderes que
estamos aquí los que somos capaces de
proponer también esas agendas y esas
conversaciones pues entonces va a ser
muy difícil que nos salgamos de esas
conversaciones tan ligeras tan
emocionales tan violentas
que están sucediendo en las redes
sociales y por último pues simplemente
decir que las personas que creen esas
historias pues yo sigo creyendo que el
talento que necesitamos detrás de
quienes creen esas historias son
personas que sean capaces de reflexionar
o pues cuyo norte sea pensar en la
sociedad nuestra y pensar y conectarse
con lo que una sociedad como la colombia
o la de bogotá o la de nuestras ciudades
considera relevante e interesante bello
justo o verdadero y esa es una capacidad
que nos dan las ciencias humanas y
sociales y yo pensaría que ese es el
talento que necesitamos para tener sobre
todo en esas historias pistas sobre lo
que le da sentido a lo que hacemos ya lo
que somos
ah
[Aplausos]